Oh
it's almost impossible to guess the
number of communicating civilizations
that are out there because as I've
described the fraction of planets on
which life emerges is not known it could
be anything from zero to well and so
they the uncertainties in that number
really mean that it's a fool's errand
trying to estimate the further
consequences of their being intelligent
life and communicating civilizations but
you can of course go to an optimist and
I guess there's no one more optimistic
than Frank Drake himself and say how
many do you think are out there in the
galaxy and he reckons 10,000 that's his
currently best guess well there is so
you can then ask well then how close is
the nearest one likely to be to us and
it's going to be a few hundred light
years so let's take a thousand light
years as the round bigger now the
problem here is that a civilization
that's a thousand light years away
doesn't know we exist they don't know
that we have radio telescopes here on
earth because they see earth as it was a
thousand years ago nothing can travel
faster than light so however good their
instruments they can't see in effect the
future they can only see earth as it was
a thousand years ago so there's no
particular reason they should be sending
us messages at this time and if you put
yourself in the position of a SETI
enthusiast on this hypothetical distant
planet going to a granting agency and
saying there's a really interesting
planet over there earth that we've
studied it very carefully and we can see
they built huge structures like the
pyramids on this great wall in China we
think some millenium soon they may have
radio telescopes could we have some
money to start broadcasting and I can
tell you
well the grant agency would say it would
say that's a great idea you come back in
a few thousand years when you know
they're actually on the air and would
give you the money to send them some
messages and and that's a situation
we're in so I think it's a bit of a
fool's errand to be looking for
deliberately beamed messages we might
stumble across a message intended for
somebody else or it may be that
we see a beak on us or something like
that
these things are long shots and so my
feeling is well we should carry on
trying because who knows what's out
there but meanwhile we should be finding
other ways of looking for easy
the history of the galaxy is pretty well
understood and the Stars started forming
towards the center first the age of the
galaxy is a little over thirteen billion
years earth is only four-and-a-half
billion years the very earliest stars
didn't have the sort of heavier elements
like carbon and oxygen and so on that
are necessary for life but after a short
period of time these elements were
manufactured when the first stars made
them and then blow up and spread them
around and so in the early days the the
main action was towards the center of
the galaxy where these superstars had
exploded and then right out on the edges
of the galaxy there was a positive these
heavy elements and so over time what has
happened is that this Goldilocks zone
which could support life has expanded
out and where some way in in the middle
suburbs of our Milky Way galaxy the
Goldilocks zone is is now moved out to
here and but that's because of course
we've where earth and the solar system
is only about 1/2 or 1/3 as old as the
galaxy so if we're thinking about old
civilizations those that from the long
time ago and there were stars and
planets around long before Earth even
existed then these are going to be
towards the center of the galaxy that's
a place to look if you think there
ancient civilizations that have have
made beacons or some other way of
attracting attention